when the standard on the other side of
of that endemic
if you'll survive it
when you'll be the winner and
and that's what motivated us you know
we've we've seen whiskey work we had the
chance to see the Glimpse
of how it looks when it works how it
looks when kind of the hockey stick
starts to grow
and then it stops so
can you can you let go of a dream like
that can you let go of that moment I
think we we just couldn't we love
we love what we do we love working
together
come to 20 minute leaders just sit back
relax and learn from the leaders of
today if it's a journey
let's get started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very very much for for being
here for joining me and we're going to
have a great time over these 20 minutes
diving into your world and diving into
the world of whiskey and talking a
little bit about your journey and and at
the end hopefully leaving knowing why
you have the best job in the world and
the best company in the world and so
thank you again for joining your town
tell me a little bit about you know your
background leading up to the formation
of whiskey
well uh yeah it's so it started very
very early for me because I was lucky to
grow up in France and uh I was born very
uh passionate skier parents so they were
taking me since I'm four year old
actually to skill
and I think since then so it's 30 32
years ago I'm skiing or snowboarding
every year uh in many different places
in the world
so that that's where the connection
started and the other part is the the
part of of just programming and loving
to to build stuff I was
I started my journey in uh in the Army
as a programmer I was in the A200 unit
um went to programs I was five years
there then went to some startups in the
industry decided I don't want to code
after like 10 years I did it I wanted to
do some other stuff and I actually went
to study Communications with IDC
well it was super interesting and I
really fell in love with designing
products thinking about Solutions
and the old Journey began at the Zell
program of the ISC is a cell
entrepreneurship program
and uh that's that's where literally the
the the whiskey Story begins where I met
David my co-founder and that's what was
really the sort of tell me a little bit
about the ideation process for whiskey
back from when when it was what is sort
of the market looking like and what is
the sort of the you know what is the why
behind the formation of whiskey
so
we started seven years ago and it was
basically me David and ayele that was
with us uh back then in the team we had
to think of ideas
of what we will do in our cell
entrepreneurship here
and both David and me are friends skiers
and we're we're planning those trips
every year and we just know the pain
from a consumer Point uh point of view
we know how hard it is to find the Flies
the transfers the right apartment
where should I ski where should I land
where do I buy the ski passes how do I
rent equipment and on and on and on
especially when you're doing it with big
groups
and for me we are a group of around 15
12 12 15 sometimes 18 people from a lot
that we're all going ski together
snowboard actually
and organizing it is a nightmare is a
nightmare because you need to chase
everyone you need to share the the the
the Excel sheets and then you pay for
the flights people are sending you the
money
I think that's from that pain we started
the company we knew the pain very very
well and we wanted to solve it so
that's kind of how we started if you
want uh
the research phase we start building our
MVP around that and eventually started
designing the product and designing the
solution and over the years uh of course
reached to what you see today at Whiskey
uh which is that self-service funnel
let's just make it everything so simple
uh when you book your ski trip
let's talk a little bit about the very
first people that
um onboarded to this platform so a
little bit about the consumer Behavior
side
you know what is what does it get
for you what does it take for you to get
people to to trust what you're doing is
trust an issue how do you get people to
to make those initial bookings so that
you can start validating what you're
doing
um so we you know we start with an MVP
kind of okay we we targeted the UK
Market as our as our as our main Market
there's around two million skiers a year
going out of the UK they both have they
all have the same problem of finding
their flights transfers keep us all of
that all together into a package now we
started by just
we build a landing page that has kind of
a search uh bar into it and we let them
fill their search by where they're
flying from which Resort they want to go
to how big the group the group is what
dates they want to do and eventually
they left leads and we started calling
them and
um we understood that
the customization
and the choice
uh they want to see is very important so
they want to have a tailor-made trip if
you want to to exactly fit their needs
and each one of those customers at
different needs one was a family one of
the good friends one was a couple
um and secondly is the it's it's the
choice
and the price points and you know as ski
trips the price point can go from
the lower stand you can go to Bulgaria
and to a two-star hotel and pay I know
500 euros for you for your trip
or you can go to uh courchevel
take a
and nice Chalet and pay around ten
thousand dollars or even twenty thousand
dollar person so the the price variation
is very big and I think
the it
the
option to kind of
make those preferences preferences work
for you as a customer were very
important and that's how we kind of
brought in our first customers in we've
let them see a very big variety
and and get very good deals I think
that's always the end game right doesn't
matter how good your your product is if
you're not giving a good deal
for the ski trip itself nobody will book
so that was always on our mind that
when we decided
so what what was this to walk me through
a little bit about whiskey through the
years and I know that you know we can
also jump to around what's happening
right before covet and then you know
what what covid what Journey covet took
you as as an entrepreneur
um yeah so it hit it would it literally
have kind of two phases or if you want
three phases to Whiskey because
the kind of from
two students with an idea until covet we
will we we bootstrap for a year and a
half we build a we've built a team we've
built the product we've got the first
customers in
um and that was kind of the first years
that we we hustled the wave up there
like nobody believed in it in the
beginning we're doing b2c travel in
Israel you can imagine the investors up
until today you go to VCS they say okay
why are you doing skiing and why I mean
how big is it they don't understand your
market right
it's not 100 time yeah it took us time
to show them that to show to show the
customers to show the conversion rates
the the to LTV all of those metrics
that make sense uh and make whiskey
available business
and it took us four years uh to grow
from 300 customers on the first season
to more than 4 000 customers was it was
very not a very good journey up till
that day
and we were on a very good direction but
then kovit came
and kovid was
I mean I can't explain
how bad it is because you imagine watch
the whole startup of what you're doing
your whole
your whole Market disappears it doesn't
exist
um it's like if Spotify
uh one day all the words stop listening
to music right what do you do and for us
it was in the middle of the Season we
had to cancel
almost 2 000 ski trips uh a long day
because everybody calls you in that one
day that they closed uh on the on the
ski resorts and we had to repatriate
like 200 people that were stuck in
Resorts and no way yeah so you find
yourself in this kind of chaotic place
and and it was a few months but we were
just
handling the chaos but on the same time
understanding that we need to let go all
the employees because we won't be able
to to keep them and we need to save the
company somehow
and the yeah that was
and and every time I'm kind of thinking
about it so
crazy memories uh okay so you so you
make the team leaner and you are aware
that you know the product that you're
offering is only going to be viable when
when the market allows it to be viable
again what do you do then I mean you
stole the company you have a product
what are you doing you know what's the
you know doing the lockdowns and there's
quite a few things happening
so you have the chaos in the beginning
and it's lasting for a few good month
because
you make all the cancellations and you
have a lot of of customers cancellations
and and and angry people that you handle
and then this quiet it's just
you know like
like that quiet wow
and we're we're sitting together so
David Pavel uh and me my two co-founders
uh sitting in a room
and thinking what whatever whatever why
are we doing it like what what's gonna
happen is there's gonna be a ski when
ski is going to come back when travel is
going to come back
and we're sitting in the lockdowns and
just
on the same time thinking about
our futures our our kind of personal
lives and and trying to convince
ourselves to keep on doing it on the
same time we are
even more believing in the product we we
even more believe in in the opportunity
because when the standard on the other
side of of that pandemic
if you'll survive it you'll be the
winner and
and that's what motivated us you know
we've we've seen whiskey work we had the
chance to see the Glimpse
of how it looks when it works how it
looks when kind of the hockey stick
starts to grow
and then it stops so
yeah can you can you let go of a dream
like that can you let go of that moment
I think we we just couldn't we love
we love what we do we love working
together
and one last thing I've had is that you
know we are free so even when one is
less motivated
you have two others that will keep him
up and and we had that flow with each
other and and try to keep up
uh with eventually good at optimism
yeah how long did that period Last by
the way
a ferocity for almost two years
that we stayed uh so three of us and one
employee of ours that we kept
um yeah we have to rate it through you
continue building the platform during
those two years you continue building
Pro building more features and I mean
what do you how do you
create a road map for these two years
what are you focusing on during that
time because you also don't know how
long it's going to last right
yeah so the good thing about it is that
you you have a lot of time
and I have a lot of time and and you're
not running on customers you're not
running on making more sales
you have time to kind of redesign and
improve your funnels improve your
customer journey and that's what we did
we refought every process every bit of
the of the product
to just make it Flawless and and make it
100 self-service which was not
at the time before covered you know
people were falling in the funnel we
were catching the leads calling them
with a kind of a light touch sales team
um
and from the the other side of
government we just decided we're going
to do only self-service so no phone
numbers we're not going to catch leads
we're just gonna make them uh and do it
and and you know we're gonna make it
work that was gonna the idea
that the good thing is I went a lot
better than what we we thought you know
we've put some uh forecasts we've we if
we had to raise uh
we have to we have to raise a round to
save the company in the middle of the
lockdowns very hard to raise because we
have to convince investors to invest in
a b2c ski business whilst there's no
skiffer almost a year and a half
and but we had to put some forecasts and
we we've put the numbers that you know
things will come back
and September 2021
and was kind of the last lockdown that
didn't happen we started seeing the tick
blowing up and the thing started like
climbing very fast from that day
suddenly I saw people booking it looked
like the winter is going to come and
there's not gonna be lockdowns
and pretty
it ran very fast there was only grown in
that year so there was some kind of uh
another last bump for the story uh but
for us it was already the third time we
were canceling trips
so we were already used to
to handle that situation
but in terms of sales in terms of the
the
product the product Market said
everything was there
and we did that is in we did
almost three and a half times what we
did pre-covered and we were only seven
people uh in the company last year so
not showed a lot and and that's what
actually brought her to this day today
we are doing 10 times more than 10 times
what we did pre-covered wow
um we and we are less the team right so
it's amazing to see it working today
so how much of it do you think it's a
market change versus a team or product
change that's letting that's leading to
to this amazing growth
um I would say it's mostly the product
change and I think the market the market
got more used to book online but
it's not like that they weren't doing it
before it's more of us understanding
where the product didn't work
us using the time to just focus and
improve everything that we know of and
we had a lot of data we had four years
of data
of customers that's telling us uh what's
working and what's not
um so mostly it's our side and I would
say and it's about also the Bold
decisions we had to take you know is it
if you say I'm gonna do only
self-service and no matter what I'm I'm
not gonna catch leads to try and sell
them
but I'm gonna make this work
so it still is the best chance that it
will really work because if not you
always try to find the shortcuts and
this time we just didn't use any
shortcut we went for the
for the vision we went for what we
believed in and
and it worked and I think you know it's
it's always a game of time and
experience with those things you can't
you can't have the right solution and on
the first day
so where are you heading to from now so
we ski in a few years where do you see
it
so we see it as as the the global leader
for ski trips and eventually the the
place where a skier or snowboarder from
anywhere
I can just go as key everywhere they
want we started connecting uh new
Resorts now
also in Europe and now also in Canada
and the US and we start targeting kind
of this area which is cool because
you know we get to to meet the resorts
and we get to go to these events and
also ski in some amazing places uh in
the world
yeah and awful job
but uh you discovered
that
it's skin is huge it's and it's kind of
the same in every country but every
country and every area has their own
kind of special thing around skiing so I
think that learning about it connecting
those those those those
destinations and enabling to our
customers that's that's right before for
destinations abroad that you were
onboarding you mentioned
a geographical evolution of the places
that you're that you're supporting what
what is it what is sort of the
onboarding process look like from from
both sides of the market you have the
consumers and you have the resorts
themselves how do you how do you tap
into a new location that you've ever
been to a new geographical location
so in terms of yeah if this donation
wise I'll start with that because you
need to have the destination before you
can of course sell it to their customers
it's a lot about
you know building relationship with the
industry
and and you you get you got to
understand your industry and in skiing
specifically is specifically is very
I would say traditional in Europe many
of the places are run by family owned
hotels and um
it's privately owned ski resorts that
you need to kind of develop the
relationship
explain them about what's an API and
what's what's online booking many of
them in the beginning seven years ago
didn't know what we're talking about so
it was a lot about teaching them and
explaining them what what we want to do
I think now it's it's more
um it's more of a known thing and it's
easier for us to connect also because
whiskey has become
yeah kind of a revolutionizing brand in
the in the market
but uh it's always about going to the
places going to the events uh meeting
the people face to face and and
developing those relationship and those
connections that the tech connections
that enables you to to get the inventory
uh from from the market point of view
from consumer point of view is is it's
all about marketing it's about
understanding the consumers
uh we're working today at four uh four
Origins so the UK Ireland us
and Israel of course
um but now we're expanding and as you're
expanding you you understand that every
every consumer had sees it a bit
differently than the other one
one is taking a week long ones taking in
and just a short weekend
um so
I'm wishing you uh wishing you best of
luck with with everything that you're
doing uh with whiskey and I look forward
to getting my booking my own made
trouble through whiskey myself and uh I
can only imagine what it was like going
through two years of just waiting to see
what will happen in the market getting
cutting down the team to be a lean team
still believing in the product and and
so I really want to thank you for taking
this time to chat with me and stay safe
and stay healthy
yeah Michael thank you very much for the
time from your interview and uh keep on
doing great stuff
thank you very very much thank you thank
you
[Music]